hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
his second meditation Rene Descartes
will bring up the example of a piece of
wax one that has been taken recently
from a honeycomb and this is a sort of
stand-in or example or paradigm of any
extended object that we would want to
know something that we've experienced
through engagement with the senses so
you could think about you know a
chalkboard for example or a piece of
clothing or anything else that you like
now you might if you've followed along
Dick Hart's meditations to this point
say well why is he bringing up anything
remotely like that things that are
external to myself hasn't he just
imagined to himself that he doesn't have
a body
that the external world doesn't exist
isn't he applying this methodological
doubt and even bringing in the idea of
an evil demon or genius who spends all
of his attention deceiving me and the
answer is yes but what Descartes is done
is that we're going to treat everything
as if it's false that doesn't mean
we can't actually investigate it because
the goal of des cartes meditations is
not to be a skeptic or introduce
skepticism for its own sake its to at
some point in time arrived at certainty
about truths having to do with himself
with God with the universe with things
and the body as well so he is going to
talk first about do I actually have a
conception of body and he does he does
in fact have a general conception of
body he says for what belongs to the
body I don't actually doubt anything
about its nature but I think that I
actually know it quite distinctly
because if I wanted to explain following
the notions that I had I would have
described it in such a manner by body
core in French I understand all that can
be limited or terminated tammini in
French by some sort of shape or figure
or structure figure in French write
everything that can be contained in some
sort of place and which fills that space
in such a way that every other body is
excluded from it that's a part of the
general conception of body as well isn't
it something that can be sensed either
by touch or by sight or by hearing or by
taste or by odor so physical objects
that can actually be sensed by us in the
world he goes on and he says that can be
moved in multiple ways not by itself but
by something else by which it is touched
and from which it receives some sort of
impression or some sort of impulse some
sort of force so this is a good way for
us to unpack what we mean in general by
body and notice that at that point in
the discussion Descartes is talking
about this in a very generic sense he's
not saying this body or that body he's
just say
any body whatsoever this is the general
conception that I have of what it means
to be a body or to be as you would say
later an extended substance so what
about the piece of Wax why does he come
to that that comes a little bit later in
the discussion and this is after he's
already talked about the fact that he
knows that he exists and so long as he
thinks he exists he's a thinking thing
then he starts talking about well what
about these ideas that I have of things
besides myself are they just pure
figments of my as we would say
imagination Descartes might not use
exactly that term so he says let's begin
by considering the most common things
the most ordinary things and we will
come I hope that we will come to grasp
them most distinctly and so what should
that be you know bodies that we touch
and that we see so he says I'm not going
to talk here about about about bodies in
general because you know the general
notions that we have of things they
could be confused so you notice that
he's being extraordinarily careful here
he says let's pay attention to a
particular kind of body a particular
thing let's take a piece of wax now at
the time that he's writing you don't
know whether he has the wax in front of
him or is just you know remembering this
or imagining it or something like that
but he says let's take him a piece of
wax a morsel the seer which has just
come to be taken from the honey hive
right the hosh he says there is no
there's there's still the the sweetness
of the honey that it contained it also
retains a little bit of the odor of the
flowers from which the honey was
harvested its color its shape its size
are apparent to us we can see them we
can touch them it is hard it is cold we
touch it and if if you knock on it
it'll give out some sort of sound so he
says all the things that can be
distinctly known about a body are found
in this so you know think about that
image for a moment run your mind over it
thinking about what it's like to sense
something as hard as cold as you know
waxy if we want to talk about the feel
of it or anything like that the smell
the the tastes all of these things that
is what the piece of wax is isn't it
that's what our senses tell us the piece
of wax is but what happens when we start
to experiment what happens when we for
example as Descartes is going to do in
this take it near a fire what happens to
those sensible qualities they change in
very important ways don't they he goes
on and he says whatever they're remained
of its flavor exhales it you know
dissipates into the air the odor
disappears as well the color changes the
figure is lost its greatness or size
augments it grows it becomes liquid it
heats up you can barely touch it and if
you knock on it it doesn't give any sort
of sound so he says does the same wax
remain there in that change and if the
wax is merely the sensible qualities
what answer would you have to give to
that the answer would be no because the
sensible qualities have all changed and
yet we don't think that the wax is no
longer there
we don't even say it's no longer wax
it's just something different we say no
no the wax has changed the wax itself
has to be something other than those
sensible properties or qualities there
right so he says
certainly it can't be anything that I
took in by the intermediary of the
census because all of the things that
fell under taste or smell or sight or
touch or hearing all of these things are
changed and yet the same wax remains so
what is it that I think the wax is it's
not the sweetness of the honey it's not
the agreeable smell of the flowers nor
is it this whiteness nor is it this
figure nor is it this sound but rather
it's a body which just a little bit
before appeared underneath these forms
which now I can take in without these
others so he says well okay then
properly speaking what is it that I
imagine when I'm thinking of something
of this sort so he says let's be very
careful with this and distance ourself
from everything that only that doesn't
belong to the wax let's see what remains
here
so he says certainly there's nothing
other than something that is extended
flexible and shapeable move AB in French
so he says can't I imagine that this
this wax once round is capable of
becoming square and passing from a
square to a figure triangular and he
says well it's not that because I can
conceive it capable of receiving an
infinity of similar changes and I don't
know how to run over that infinity by my
imagination so it's not something that
I'm actually able to take in by
imagination so how do I then actually
understand what the piece of wax is so
he says well what is this extension is
it also unknown since the wax and it and
you know that that's at the bottom
becomes larger and is found to be
greater than it was
when it was when it was a hard figure
and if I heat it up even more it becomes
even larger and he says I don't concede
if I yeah I don't conceive clearly and
according to truth what the wax is if I
don't think of it as capable of
receiving many of these sorts of
varieties
according to extension then I would have
ever imagined so what is it that I
understand it to be I grasp it as a type
of extended substance and how do I do
that I'm not doing it through the senses
at all I've already stripped those away
am i doing it through what he calls the
common sense the imagination the cart
equates these to the common sense I
should mention is not what we typically
mean these days when we mean common
sense but rather the unification of the
senses of sight hearing smell taste
touch that allows us to produce an
object for ourselves so you know the
common sense you could say is the nexus
the juncture of all of the senses
Descartes says no we're not going to
actually understand what the wax is in
its its general conception of body
except through what he calls the
intellect or the understanding the Anton
demo in French and this is a higher
Faculty this is not simply dependent on
images this is you could say a pure form
of thoughts Descartes thinks that this
is also something that is not very easy
to use apart from the senses and the
imagination you know we can do it
perhaps for a short amount of time but
it is certainly something possible for
us and because we have that we're able
to grasp what things genuinely are and
so he goes on and he tells us that what
we've remarked or what we've noticed
here about the wax can
be applied to all other things that are
exterior to me and which I encounter
outside of myself right
we understand extended things in part by
you know he says there there under the
the clothing of their visible
appearances right or sensual appearances
we don't want to confine it solely to
the visible but when we strip those
clothing away and we and we encounter it
completely naked
we're doing so by means of the
understanding the same thing that we use
to understand ourselves to be able to
say I think I am right in the discourses
or I am I exist because I engage in
thinking that's carried out by the
intellect or understanding we don't
grasp things truly as they are except by
use of the intellect or understanding so
he says if this notion or knowledge of
the wax seems to be more clear more
distinct after it has been discovered
not only by sight or touch but also by
many other causes after so much evidence
distinction and and clarity I can also
understand myself because all the
reasons that serve to understand and
conceive the nature of the wax or any
other body can even more easily and more
evidently be applied to the nature of my
own spirit so the piece of wax he says
at the end of this example has helped to
illustrate more than just what it would
be like to take in a sensible object
it's helped us to understand a
fundamental distinction between ways of
grasping things so that we then can
proceed more securely and arrive at the
point where we
indeed attain certainty
you